la société air france peut être
satisfaite puisque la compagnie
française affiche 85 millions de francs
de bénéfice pour l'année 83 même
concorde a atteint son équilibre alors
avant de retrouver monsieur giraud d le
patron d'air france examinons les
raisons qui expliquent ces bons chiffres
avec alain doublé ski air france d'abord
la compagnie ne fait pas dans la nuance
83 années de réussite complète après un
déficit en 1982 air france a dégagé 81 5
millions de francs de bénéfices l'an
dernier la baisse du prix du pétrole y
est pour beaucoup
mais une grande part de cette réussite
est due à des efforts de gestion
considérable si le trafic passager est
en stagnation + 2 %
air france augmente au trafic fret de
près de 20% devenant ainsi la troisième
compagnie mondiale en matière de fret
même concorde a réalisé des bénéfices en
1983 a dit air france qui bien sûr
enlève les frais d'amortissement payés
par l'état
air inter résultats plus nuancé en
attendant les chiffres officiels on peut
avancer que le trafic passager
progressera d'environ huit et demi pour
cent mais les résultats financiers eux
n'en font pas autant
il devrait être en baisse par rapport à
ceux de 82 le tgv est un très sérieux
concurrent sur la ligne paris-lyon ainsi
air inter aura transporté sept cent
mille passagers sur cette ligne au lieu
d 1 million 400 mille escompté ut à aura
fait en 1983 un chiffre d'affaires
supérieur à 82 mais il y a un mais cela
grâce à la vente d'avions par la
compagnie en effet brut et à le trafic
est en baisse surtout au niveau du fret
mais revenons à air france on président
nous explique les raisons de la réussite
pour nous a été également de nous
retourner vers les marchés étrangers
pour compenser ce que nous risquions de
perdre sur le marché français du fait
des mesures de contrôle des changes
et puis enfin une action extrêmement
énergique en matière de fret qui nous a
permis un développement spectaculaire de
19%
tout ceci ça nous a donné de bon
coefficient tant pis agents passage une
bonne utilisation de notre flotte pour
le fret
puis parallèlement à ça un milliard
d'économies d'un milliard d'économies
d'abord sur le pétrole et ceci pas
entièrement grâce à nous bien entendu me
sentais bien
tout de même 1 milliard d'économies
également sur les frais financiers sur
les la gestion et une gestion serrée
rigoureuse mais pas dans des conditions
dramatiques pas de licenciements pas
suppressions d'activités simplement une
gestion de tous les jours attentive
rigoureuse et aboutissant finalement ce
résultat
en ce qui concerne les passagers qu'elle
quel est le trafic qui se développe le
plus c'est ce que sont les billets cher
veut dire première classe classe
affaires ou est ce que sont les billets
à tarif réduit écoutez ces dernières
années c'était plutôt le transport de
masse donc des billets à tarif réduit
mais en 83 contenu du contrôle des
champs je peux dire que le le
développement c'est plutôt axé sur le
trafic d'affaires ce trafic moyenne
contribution